[Music]
my name is Tim I had the greatest
parents ever rise and shine take your
kid to work day
really it was just the three of us the
Templeton's life was perfect until that
one fateful day meet your new baby boom
[Music]
he wears a suit he's like a little man
he carries a briefcase there's no one
else things that's oh I don't know a
little freaky will you carry lamb-lamb
around until you were like this is not
about lamb-lamb trust me one day you're
gonna love him with all of your heart
never
[Music]
the usual procedures sleep deprivation
hundred strikes
they're very disorienting but I think
the kid might be on to me Judy I got a
deal with the K ID you can talk uh
googoo gaga
no you can really doc fine I can talk
now let's see if you can listen get me a
double espresso and see if there's
someplace around here with decent sushi
I'd kill for a spicy tuna roll right
about now get yourself a little
something
[Music]
are you let's just say I'm the boss just
wait till mom and dad find out about
this
power nap uh you were saying
[Music]
you